the Ukrainian offensive has been
spectacularly successful so far and his
left rushing force is completely off
balance in the Northeast and under
increasing pressure in the Southwest
so the ukrainians might keep pushing
from kharkiv into the donbass encircling
more Russian positions as they go the
Russians were defeated with their backs
to the Oscar River
and if the offensive continues it isn't
obvious where the Russians will reform
their front and try to Halt it halt the
offensive from there but Russia still
controls almost 20 percent of Ukrainian
territory and neither Ukraine nor the
West should get carried away by these
successes one thing we're all clear
about is that President Putin Won't Give
Up regardless of these reverses and
Russia is a big country with big
resources to bring to bear over the long
term
nevertheless the ukrainians now control
the Key Road between satovay and cremena
and they look as if they might be trying
to in to encircle the Russians from the
north into Donetsk and that gives the
Russians a problem if the Russians
cannot or will not fight for severeign
then their next plausible defense line
is probably some sort of major dog leg
further to the east
whatever they do the Russians can't
reinforce their positions very quickly
somewhere they're going to have to dig
in and wait for winter
you know the Russians invaded with a
force of 190 000 a totally inadequate
number to conquer and then control a
nation of 44 million people within the
second biggest land area in Europe and
they drew that from a peacetime Army of
only 280 000 men and an internal
security force of rozgaria 400
000 men but Russia had reserved forces
of two million people who who have
served somewhere in the military over
the last five years and of course they
have the possibility of greatly
increasing the conscription of eligible
men for service among a population of
144 million
all the present angst in Russian State
TV over whether the country should now
mobilize to fight Ukraine in a
full-scale war may actually be the
kremlin's attempt to prepare the Russian
public for some real sacrifices next
year
and President Putin can only justify
that idea by contending that in reality
Russia is now fighting War for its
survival against the rest of Europe